not tall enough for for this work for
kids
[Music]
are you doing
we're joined in that barrel
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're such a smuggle ahead our friends
Jenner says hi he says you guys take
away the attention from hi friends it's
Jen at sunshine farm I just went outside
I visited the animals even though it's
super cold outside it made me feel a lot
more at peace and it reminded me why we
moved here in the first place
so I wanted to tell you the story of how
we were able to buy our farm at the ages
of 22 and Chris who was 23 at the time
we've had so many people come to our
house and think I'm the daughter of
somebody who lives here they'll say
where are your mom and dad not here very
California I've had somebody say you
look too young to live here I had
someone asked me did you inherit the
farm and it's really interesting because
I wish they would just ask me how are
you able to buy a farm at such a young
age
because that's a question I can answer
so I wanted to answer that for you today
just like talking about our debt free
journey this is a very personal journey
and it's going to look very different
depending on your circumstances which we
all have such different circumstances
but I want to encourage you that if you
have a dream that you can try to make it
happen and that there are in many ways
things you can do now to start preparing
for that dream to become a reality so in
Chris and I had just gotten married and
we purchased a little home in the city
of Rochester the home was really cute it
was a perfect size for us had a lot of
character but it wasn't a very urban
environment so we were very limited in
what we could do in terms of
homesteading we did start a little 4 by
6 raised bed and we grew a couple tomato
plants a couple pepper plants and maybe
a cucumber plant but I wasn't interested
in gardening at that point the only
thing I was really interested in was
having my own horse around that time I
started horseback riding again a local
farm that actually isn't too far from
where we are now and I just found that
that experience was so peaceful for me
and I felt like I found myself when I
was on a horse near a
so we had only been in our house for
about eight or nine months when we
started talking about the possibility of
moving to a farm I have been
experiencing some weird health issues
that caused a lot of digestive problems
nerve issues and muscle aches and pains
headaches and just general depression
and anxiety about what was going on with
my body I started learning that the only
way in my body was responding to healing
was through my diet and through adopting
a really heavy plant-based diet with a
lot of natural foods fresh foods and
really avoiding things like oils alcohol
high levels of sugars and the biggest
trigger for me I found out was bread I
learned at that time that I actually
have an intolerance to bread and wheat
products so I unfortunately have to
adopt a gluten-free diet as I was
experiencing a lot of health issues I
thought what are we waiting for life is
so short I could have been diagnosed
with something much more serious and I
don't want to waste another minute
dreaming instead of trying to find a way
to make our dreams a reality
I felt like we could do it now the
reason I thought it was a possibility is
because when we bought our first little
house in the city we actually only knew
that Chris would be working at the time
he had a job lined up I wasn't sure what
I was going to do next so we knew we
could afford that little house on one
income once I started working a
full-time job
even though I wasn't making a lot of
money we were able to save almost my
entire salary and put that towards what
we used as a down payment and closing
costs for our farm while we didn't get
anything really back from our small
house in the city just because we only
lived there for a short period of time
we were able to save really well because
we were only living according to that
one income that we had planned for so as
our income grew and the money coming in
grew we didn't up our cost of living we
kept it the same and even we're tight in
many instances so that we could save
really well for this firm now I know a
lot of people our age will spend their
extra income on things like travel and
going out to eat but I've always been a
very frugal person I don't like to spend
money and I really wanted my dream to
come true so I was very determined
to save well to save hard to make it
possible now we were able to do this
because we lived in a house where the
mortgage and taxes was under $800 a
month it was pretty low cost of living
where we were because of that low cost
of living and that unexpected extra
income that allowed us to save a lot
really in a short period of time to be
able to move where we are now where we
are now is more than double what we were
paying when we are in that little house
in the city it's a lot more expensive
we're able to live out our dream here
and to us it's worth it and over time
through our debt free journey and as our
incomes grow we will do the same thing
we did when we lived in our previous
home and we'll keep our expenses as
close as possible to what they are now
and even lower them where we can so that
way we can pay off more of our debt
quicker and and be able to experience
that financial freedom it wasn't just
saving for a year to move here there's
that whole history of what allowed us to
be able to buy our first home right
after we got married in the first place
I've actually saved my entire time
through college and even some of my high
school graduation money to be able to do
something with the money I didn't really
know what I was going to use it for but
I I kept saving it wasn't until we got
engaged and Chris and I were looking at
rental properties that we just decided
hey why can't we just buy a house why
not
we haven't old kind of this is what your
life should look like you should rent an
apartment you should save you should buy
a house in a starter neighborhood I just
didn't like that idea I don't like
living according to an expectation just
because it's an expectation for me if
something's possible and it's what we
want I'd like to try to find a way to
make it happen
at first my told Chris I wanted to move
to a farm he was very skeptical he did
not think we could afford it and he was
concerned that I was dreaming a little
too big a little too soon and that's
fair but he let me dream and eventually
my dream became his dream and he was
willing to look a big reason we were
able to buy this property it dropped
down in price significantly before we
even looked at it so we knew it was in
our price range and then the second
thing was the sellers were willing to
contribute to the closing costs which
they call seller concessions we had more
flexibility in what we could put down
and that enabled us to have some will
for an emergency fund so we weren't
completely housebroke I will say we did
not put a lot down we only put 5% down
on this house which is what allowed us
to buy this farm I'm in our early 20s it
takes a long time to save a good amount
of money and while we could have lived
in the city for a few more years and
saved better I just felt like I didn't
want to spend my years waiting for a
dream to become realized we decided that
we could financially do it and it meant
we didn't have as much equity in our
home right away but it was worth it to
us to be able to start this dream early
on what this means for us is that we
don't have the flexibility to leave our
jobs our cost of living with this farm
is more expensive than we're able to
take on with one income but we love love
it here and we both enjoy our jobs
somebody asked me how we learn to save
well and my biggest tip would be just to
really cut any extra expenses as you can
and the second thing would be as your
income increases keep your cost of
living the same so that you can save
anything extra that's coming in and then
you'll end up with a lot more than you
expected someone also asked what we do
for a living that allows us to do this
Chris is an energy engineer I work at a
local university where I do project
coordination both of our jobs are not
high high earning positions we're not
you know taking in a ton of money each
month but we do have stable careers that
we were able to get into because we went
to four-year undergraduate institutions
there are three more questions I wanted
to answer in this video that my
Instagram followers sent me the first
one someone asked what our first project
was here at the farm and that was adding
chickens we bought a chicken coop and
Chris built a chicken run and we added
the chickens about at the same time we
did add our miniature horse Justin and a
couple months later we added TJ our
Paint Horse I talked about this more in
the video titled two years the farm and
I will link this at the end another
question someone asked is how much space
we actually have we have 12 and a half
acres here about six to seven acres our
pasture a few acres our woods and then
the rest is like
front yard side yard and things like
that someone else asked if we make sell
stuff or find another way to bring an
income for a farm no not at the moment
and we're not making anything from the
farm other than maybe four dollars here
and there for free-range organic eggs
but that's obviously not going to make a
dent in the mortgage all of our income
right now is coming from our two
full-time jobs we do have Airbnb in our
guest bedroom where we rent out our room
and a bathroom which is right near the
room on the weekends this is more
popular in the summertime but I'm
actually going to be having a
photographer renting out the space this
weekend so that brings in just a little
over a hundred dollars every weekend
that somebody rents it although we don't
have it 50 weekend's out of the year we
probably only have like 10 to 15 each
year and you do have to take into
account the cost of cleaning and we feed
them breakfast so there are some other
factors that go in there in that
equation as well we do possibly have
dreams of finding an old Airstream
trailer renovate evading it and renting
that out full-time I'm here on the
property maybe building a cabin or doing
something like that but those are lofty
dreams and not in the media future
another thing we took into consideration
when buying a farm property was we
didn't need a huge house our house is
only 1700s square feet we weren't
looking for something huge and that will
really change what you can afford on top
of that we were lucky with the timing of
the market and what was available in
this place had dropped significantly in
price and so we did get a little bit
lucky the house also hasn't been fully
remodeled or anything like that we were
willing to put some sweat equity into
the home and make things our own we
actually preferred that and that also
allowed us to be able to buy this place
my husband just got home what contribute
to the conversation I'll ask you some
questions and see what he has to say so
that's the story of how we were able to
buy our farm in our early 20s and I hope
that can be helpful to you if you're
dreaming of buying a farm and you're
thinking it's so far off the future you
can't even imagine being able to do it
soon
I do realize there are some situations
in both of our lives that have given us
a step-up tour
making this dream come true and I don't
want to ignore those but we also did
have to make a lot of steps towards that
on our own and those things are what
allowed us to pursue this dream and also
just being able to sacrifice other
things like travel going out to eat a
lot or fancy clothing we do make those
sacrifices so we can live this farm life
that I've always wanted and that Chris
now really enjoys
[Music]
what did you think when I first told you
I wanted to look at farm properties
I was definitely confused and hesitant I
think the confusion was because we had
only been in our previous house for
about a year and a half and then the
hesitation is just my own natural
reaction to any big idea or change it
takes me a long time to come around do
those things and to fully evaluate them
and be comfortable with them so anytime
I hear a big idea or a piece of news
it's always throws me off a little bit
how has this experience of living on a
homestead made you more willing to live
against the grain I think the wealth of
opportunities and new things that we are
somewhat forced to try but somewhat also
we just want to try it out here that's
kind of reshaped my worldview a little
bit I think the so I think getting used
to trying new things continuously it
grows my comfort zone I don't know if I
can point exactly to how things that my
environment has changed but I know
through this experience I have been much
more willing to embrace adventures and
great new experiences new projects I
think is a confidence within me that's
grown exponentially then from what it
was previously that's kind of come that
comes about in my confidence in my
abilities to do the projects that we
need together on the farm to build the
structures and shelters to do the
renovations in the house to take care of
the animals and to venture out and get
new animals we have a head before I'd
say that my confidence is probably just
growing a lot in the past two years that
we lived here what are three things that
helped us be able to purchase a farm in
early 20s I think willingness to both
the norm you saw that from the very
beginning when we got married right out
of college we also looked to purchase a
house right away so I think we kind of
have that mindset engrained into who we
are and who we are as a couple and I
think that was probably the biggest
instigator to allowing us to make this
jump I think really excuse me next day
so by the second thing that helped us
out the most was being able to save a
lot when the first Hospital inning in so
the first place we purchased it was not
a very expensive house at least compared
to you know the general market with
across the country that allowed us to
really save up a lot of our income and
that just the short span over there a
year and a half
save up a lot of the income that both
Jen and I were earning at the time and I
don't know if we had a really clear goal
or plan and how we were doing that it
was just somewhat arbitrary and we knew
that we were bringing in more than we
actually needed to spend and so we were
able to put a lot of it under the
savings account and so as a result of
that we were able to take that savings
and jump into a new farm purchase just
about a year after we got married and
purchased the first house what is your
favorite part about living on a farm my
favorite part is the freedom that it
brings about the freedom to make
decisions to try new things to embrace
what you want and to the freedom to buck
the trends above the norms that society
and our culture really tries to put on
us and enforce us think the farm in that
freedom it gives us a lot of flexibility
and it allows us to explore a lot of
things and there's something about that
freedom that I think opens up our our
lifestyle opens up our enjoyment of our
lives just increases our satisfaction of
our lives and of our marriage and the
future as well raising kids
I have a t-shirt on - who inspired so
hot
first fire of 2019 guys
[Music]
sorry the billeting got so crummy and
now it's like all yellow we'll work on
that but the last thing I wanted to say
is that neither Chris nor I had any
experience of farming going into this we
had never had chickens we didn't have
families that had farms I had ridden
horses but I'd never owned a horse and
cared for a horse we had never had goats
we didn't have a lot of experience
working with a barn or really any big
renovation projects so a lot of this has
been learning as we go and thanks to
YouTube Google and some other great
resources it hasn't been that bad so if
you're dreaming of doing this but you
feel like you wouldn't even know where
to start we'd love to answer questions
and help guide you in that process
reaches reach out send us an email
comment below and we'd love to connect
with you thank you guys for watching
this video
we hope you enjoyed hearing a little bit
about our story and we hope it's an
encouragement to you as you dream please
subscribe you can do so at the end of
this video a little circle icon you can
hit that button and hit subscribe and
like this video if you enjoyed this
style of recording and learning a little
bit more about our experience in our
journey bye guys
see you guys
[Music]